what's up everyone welcome to GameSpot
we're here to talk about some preview
Monster Hunter we saw I'm keeping that
ru hey everybody what's up I'm John Luke
and I'm joined by Ben howdy and you got
a chance to play several hours of
Monster Hunter World ice-born that I did
and I had a great time we got to kind of
see the the beginning of the the story
set up and how you get into ice-born got
to see some of the new like gathering
hub stuff got to measure on to some of
the new attacks and some of the new
features and even fight a new monster
which is really cool cool so I think
people who have checked out the beta are
familiar with maybe some of the new
attacks and the new ability is the
grappling hook all that stuff so let's
get into some of the stuff that people
haven't had a chance to check out for
themselves yes a new kind of hub area
yeah so you get like a new hub area that
is obviously got like snow in it and
everywhere and all that and they
actually swap out a lot of the NPC's
that would be in the area normally with
new ones and one of my favorites is the
new cook who it's no longer the the
rough master chef that we know but like
conical a loving mom cat creature who
promise to make you a bunch of warm food
to keep you nice and set in the coldest
of weather and it's a really good time
and I like that a lot but that sounds
adorable huh on top of that you think
that's how how good it could possibly
get it gets better because when you
actually go to the gathering hub where
you actually hang out with everyone
there's actually like these sauna hot
springs that you can kind of like take
your your palico into and pet while you
wait for your friends to get their stuff
together and go on a quest us you can do
that while you're like waiting to go in
yeah it's so like you you like walk up
to the counter you sign up for the quest
tell your friends so like do it go get
your food then you can just sit in the
sauna and just pet your your pal cat and
have a good time
all right well already I'm on board yeah
there's a lot of great oz the fanservice
things going on here we got lots of good
attention to detail and more things you
can do with your pal eCos that's
fantastic would you say do you feel like
they've made any like small quality life
improvements - there's like new hub
so I believe all of the things that you
would need to have access to are all in
the the multiplayer area so you don't
even need to leave if you don't want to
okay like blacksmith yeah all that stuff
is there any reason to go back to like
the old hub or is this sort of just like
a complete replacement I believe you
have access to everything I don't think
it like locks the content out define
where okay so like theoretically I could
maybe never have to visit the old
gathering hub yeah again if I want to I
think so we get to mess around too much
with it and they're only allowing us to
see what we were supposed to be doing
god and forward so let's talk about what
you were supposed to be doing then yeah
we got to see a little bit of the story
and kind of see how how that leads off
and how how we kind of find ourselves in
the new the new zone and I won't go too
much into it because I'm spoil it but
it's it's a pretty good setup and I kind
of feel like where they're going with
the story might be a little more
interesting and engaging than the base
game okay which it did a pretty good
purpose of the base game story as far as
yeah reason to compel you to fight a new
monster like it's nothing special but
it's it's kind of like a very wholesome
yeah like we can do it the power of
teamwork in humanity the I think this
time around they've got kind of like a
there's like a like a mystery or
something that's afoot we're trying to
solve it and I found myself a lot more
interested and engaged in it than I did
they fix that thing where you don't have
to do it separately to see a cutscene oh
yeah like you and find the monster and
then yeah yes that's still there okay
that's about right yeah kind of fun time
having all the people in the room have
to do that first and then come back oh
really even at the event yeah I imagine
they must know that's the thing and
maybe it's just decoded into the system
like hopefully like a monster hunter
world too they can fix that because that
was definitely the worst part about the
story mode yeah it's it's a bit of a
headache but it's it didn't seem like it
was slowing us down too much like it
maybe took everyone maybe five minutes
at the most and then moved already back
in on it
outside of all that stuff we got to
fight we fought the really cool like
antler t-rex that I forget its name
right now again but it's the one that
was amazing sir yeah yeah but the one
that was new that we haven't seen
anywhere was like a like a Toby kodachi
but it instead of being all electrical
it had like venom powers and I think it
could stun too and it would it would
actually poison everyone and it was
intense and it had different moves
different attack patterns it was a real
spicy time and I ended up saving the day
in the end after two of my teammates who
get got carted away so I'm just gonna
say that I did pretty well myself do you
feel like the monsters does it feel like
they're doing anything like dramatically
new are interesting or is it like this
was kind of a reskin so does it still
feel like a reskin it was I like the
move set very different it felt
different enough to make me feel like I
might have been fighting something a
little bit different but it you still
look at it you're like ah - Toby kadaj
you with snake eye right that was kind
of my issue with some of the later
monsters in the world the basement
version of world where some of them were
just kind of Rhys kins and they felt
well too similar at times yeah that one
lava oh yeah it was like I think he
thought this guy a long time ago in the
forest but now he's in love yeah I think
he's like the least fought monster in
the entire game apparently because no
one liked fighting him
[Music]
so this thing's coming out pretty soon I
mean like how are you feeling about it
overall is it you know like what do you
feel like it's gonna add to the overall
monster hunter world experience the the
main thing for me when I got done will
not done when I got towards the end of
playing World was that I just wanted
more Monster Hunter and that was kind of
the major overall feeling that I got
when I walked out of the preview is that
this is kind of just more Monster Hunter
to me and I'm really into that it's all
I really wanted just more monsters so
not a bad thing not a bad thing at all
and the the biggest things besides just
having more things to fight I really
like how the the new attacks with the
weapons work and Weavin with the use of
the clutch the clutch is really fun and
I want to mess around with it more
there's so many really cool
opportunities that you could just smack
things in the walls or control them
around or just having people jump on and
weak in certain parts of the monster and
shouting out like on attack it's like
cuz I got it here or I got its tail week
everyone pile onto it yeah it's really
cool and I like those a lot at the end
of the day it's kind of all I really
want out of a iceborn it's just like
give me more Monster Hunter world
because I like that game a whole lot
more monsters but this time with a ton
of hot drinks
don't forget your hot drinks everyone
drink the hot drink don't be the guy who
doesn't drink I'm gonna forget the hot
drink it took a leave peppers right
outside the area so you can you can get
some right off the bat bags yeah
excellent so yeah like we said game
comes out soon for console I think PC
players unfortunately they got to wait
till December I want that parody where's
the parody came no I switched over to PC
and how was I was excited to just play
on that now but I can't because they
they're making me wait but no oh well
hopefully we wanted to wait too long
yeah and for all things monster hunter
please stay tuned a game spot because
you can bet that me and Ben will be
covering it way more